we are asked are the following functions
even odd or neither so pause this video
and try to work that out on your own
before we work through it together all
right now let's just remind ourselves of
a definition for even and odd functions
one way to think about it is what
happens when you take F of negative x if
F of negative x is equal to the function
again then we're dealing with an even
function if we evaluate F of negative x
instead of getting the function we get
the negative of the function then we're
dealing with an odd function and if
neither of these are true
it is neither so let's go to this first
one right over here f of X is equal to 5
over 3 minus X to the fourth and the
best way I can think about tackling this
is let's just evaluate what F of
negative x would be equal to that would
be equal to 5 over 3 minus and
everywhere we see an X we're going to
replace that with a negative x to the
4th power now what is negative X to the
fourth power well if you multiply a
negative times a negative times a
negative how many times did I do that
if you if you take a negative to the
fourth power you're going to get a
positive so that's going to be equal to
5 over 3 minus X to the 4th which is
once again equal to f of X and so this
first one right over here F of negative
x is equal to f of X it is clearly even
let's do another example so this one
right over here G of X let's just
evaluate G of negative x and at any
point you feel inspired and you didn't
figure it out the first time pause the
video get and try to work it out on your
own well G of negative x is equal to 1
over negative x plus the cube root of
negative x and see let's see can we
simplify this any well we could rewrite
this as the negative of 1 over X and
then I could view negative x as the same
thing as negative 1 times X and so we
can factor out or I should say we could
take the negative 1 out of the radical
what is the cube root of negative one
well it's negative one so we could say -
we could say minus one times the cube
root or we could just say the negative
of the cube root of x and then we can
factor out a negative so this is going
to be equal to negative of one over X
plus the cube root of x which is equal
to the negative of G of X which is equal
to the negative of G of X and so this is
odd F of negative x is equal to the
negative of f of X so in this case it's
G of X G of negative x is equal to the
negative of G of X let's do the third
one so here we've got H of X and let's
just evaluate H of negative x H of
negative X is equal to two to the
negative X plus two to the negative of
negative X which would be two to the
positive x well this is the same thing
as our original H of X this is just
equal to H of X you just swap these two
terms and so this is clearly even and
then last but not least we have J of X
so let's evaluate J of I right all right
why let's evaluate J of negative X is
equal to negative x over 1 minus
negative X which is equal to negative x
over 1 plus X and let's see there's no
clear way of factoring out a negative or
doing something interesting where I get
either back to J of X or I get to
negative J of X so this one is neither
and we're done